[主播] 嗯，也不能说催婚，我一定要催婚，这还好刚才现场的这个导演反应速度快，蹭一下就切了。后面那块你们都没听到。重点信息全部泄露了。两两说，两两说他他会帮我帮我看看。帮我研究研究。真读假读。哎，真读假读。
[嘉宾] 这啥？酸奶啊？
[主播] 你别想没事了，别想没事了。
[嘉宾] 慢慢买货。慢慢买货。
[主播] 嗯，还是非常开心的。
[嘉宾] 我也很开心啊。因为这个我我我我们过两天给大家再去这个杂志，因为他们应该也没有想到会有这么大的订阅量。实事求是，现在世界范围内的杂志订阅量都非常低。嗯，全世界任何一个国家杂志订阅量都非常低。今晚我们卖出去的量，如果按照实际订阅量来说，可能已经是世界第一了。
[主播] 哎，乱说的。我们开玩笑的。就是叫我。我刚胡说的啊。主打一个能屈能伸。
[嘉宾] 大丈。
[主播] 对，然后这个人民文学他现在的平均订阅量其实也不高了，好多就是人可能已经不太好找了，你像他需要送货这种不太好弄。订阅的人也比较少的，但是今晚好多人他他购买之后我相信他们收到的时候社会跟家人一起去阅读和分享的。我我心一年开始我也特别建议大家在新的一年里把阅读啊当成生活中一个重要的事情，因为我们是能够明显的看到区别的。你发现你以前钱花的比如说穿衣打扮上这些有没有用？也有用，他说你开心了。但是以整个人的精神价值还有你的心理状态啊，还有你的这种认知啊，并没有因此改变。反而是这一年多以来好多人说在直播间买了好多书，书就会会一看，然后看看完之后呢，他现在整个人的这个心境都变了。他没有以前那样的焦虑，然后他也不会过度的去苛责孩子，他甚至跟人相处的时候也会更加的抽身事外。豁达，从容。这其实就是阅读给你带来的。然后这个新的，一年里头如果大家一本好杂志啊，自己看，自己家人看，其实你们就拥有了一个共同话题了，也有也有东西聊了。对吧，你看他他一年下来那几百块钱是吧，好像是。
[嘉宾] 对，200多。那么厚一本说了。不到20块钱，今天还给我们这个优惠了。优惠了。
[主播] 嗯。所以这个你可以跟家人一起看，看完了可以一起聊天。分享，我觉得那个挺好的。
[嘉宾] 对，其实在刚才访谈的过程当中，我看很多人发了共同的一句话。可能就是非常机缘巧合，比如说什么，放下手机，拿起书籍。
[主播] 对，因为我经常在咱们评论区看到说有的人说宇辉我已经是一个退休的老人了，然后以前是老师啊，以前是什么律师啊，各种工作的工作的人。其实大家现在如果说退休了有大量的时间，你就可以做这件事情就阅读。它它不仅能打发你大量的时间，还能够让你让你的生活变得丰富一些。我印象特别深刻，我以前马上过年，我以前过年跟我家人去走亲戚的时候，经常去我老舅家，就是我奶奶的弟弟。因为他是一个非常基层的一个大队长，好像是村支书吧。然后呢，他们那个村支部就会给定一些杂志，每个人都会定杂志。然后这个杂志定完之后他看完一般就会收拾的整整齐齐的垒在那，放在那。然后每年去他们家走亲戚的时候，我都会把那书全部抱走。因为他看过了，他看过他就会给我，他也很开心。那些杂志在以前小的时候书籍还不对我来说还比较难以获得，因为那会你要有很多的钱去买书其实不太现实。我那会学校那资料，我记得当时买卷子，买什么字字句片，我从来都没买过，因为回家跟家人要钱，我不好意思张口。就我爸不在家，我妈不好意思张口，我都没买过，学习资料我都没定过。我不管初中高中，学校让定的资料全都没定过。但是每年过年我去这个老舅家就把他那些杂志就抱回去，然后每周去学校拿上几本，然后利用课余时间把那些都看完了。
[嘉宾] 所以你说这种这其实就是在无形当中去影响了下一代，所以优秀是一种传承。
[主播] 嗯，也不见得就是优秀，但是它确实是一种传承，它是这种习惯的传承。
[嘉宾] 所以我觉得确实，你在读书的时候其实你真的，我们以前读历史的时候以史为鉴，对吧，从历史当中去看到很多的一钱发生的事，看到很多的人的这种行为，包括你在日常生活当中你看一些那种工具类的书，能够让你在同龄人面前是吧，突然一下子，哎，对吧，还有两个大脑，有两个大脑，以前我都不知道。所以读书确实是能够证明自己的不足。
[主播] 所以你发现我们推荐也是，你现在给很多小孩科普类的书，增长知识，孩子对世界充满好奇心嘛，他需要知识。成年人对他的有更大影响的其实不是知识，反而是智慧。嗯，智慧很多时候是判断力，是心态，是价值观，是认知，是情感，是精神内核。哎，那这些其实不是说通过科普，科普让你知到太阳光到地球需要八分20秒，没有意义。你知道这你也不会变得情绪稳定。
[嘉宾] 公民的能力。
[主播] 对吧，反而是你需要需要有有这个文学性的，然后小说啊这类东西，哲学啊，历史啊，这些东西它会让对成年人帮助更大，所以你会发现人的阅读在不同年龄段的需求其实是不一样的。嗯。新一年开始给自己制定一个阅读计划。我们也会监督你落实的。
[主播] 坚果啊，需要鹏自己拍，这个就是大桶了，就比较
[主播] 实惠一些，而且你这一桶能吃的很多，昨晚卖他是那个小盒装的，小盒装的好朋友说小盒还没吃你就完了。
[嘉宾] 咱只能加库存。
[主播] 书卖光了。
[主播] 咱这你那你们问一下他看他能开预售，预售好像都买完了。
[嘉宾] 对，这就是开过预售的。
[主播] 情绪稳定的能力确实很强。
[嘉宾] 其实我小的时候不太清楚什么叫情绪。我只知道有的时候我得赶紧跑。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 然后我妈突然带起来，我也得赶紧跑。对情绪对于小孩来讲就是
[主播] 你还要听到声音才知道跑，但你你要放我小时候放我家那你没少挨打。我跟你说我都是预判，我一般能预判我妈妈的情绪变化。我只要做完这个动作，我发现从他的这个眉眼之间啊，面部表情啊，肌肉的这个动作我发现他可能要生气了。我一般都是跑出去了，他才才生气。预判。强大的逃生能力，你知道吗？
[嘉宾] 但是你过早的就学会了什么？观察。
[主播] 察言观色。没办法，这都是生存压力呀。
[嘉宾] 对。会察言观色的孩子都是小的时候怎么讲？哎，不说了。
[主播] 都是生存压力呀。那一晚全村响彻我的哭喊声。
[嘉宾] 真的是全村人都听见了。
[主播] 邻居大娘还打得好。
[主播] 要不然我后来村里小孩女孩都不愿意跟我玩呢。
[嘉宾] 你丢人。
[主播] 你嗓门太大了。
[嘉宾] 全村就听见你挨打。
[主播] 全村就听见你整天挨打。屋子里全村都听见。
[主播] 谁愿意跟一个整天挨打哭的孩子玩啊？
[主播] 自己拍啊，朋友们。
[嘉宾] 杂志有了。
[主播] 他们说杂志有了。
[嘉宾] 说加了。
[主播] 加了。
[嘉宾] 嗯。真的。哎，你就是小时候的痛苦，长大之后就笑著说出来，这也是一种情绪的能力。
[主播] 必须的。
[嘉宾] 所以我们之前以前说喜欢看喜剧，后来发现喜剧的内核是悲剧。
[主播] 哎呀，就是对吧，把有价值的东西给揉碎了给你看。
[嘉宾] 这给你表现，这给你展示他的伤疤。蔡老师有一个那个写的特别好，刚才听那个两老师说，说他的那个伤疤像是绽放的花蕾，花蕊一样去展示给你，这得多么勇敢的一件事。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 内心强大。
[主播] 这我们就一直卖这一个吗？
[嘉宾] 没有，我们这还没怎么讲。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 这坚果呀。
[嘉宾] 这啥？
[主播] 松子550克，开心果500克。
[嘉宾] 因为他他里头包含了东西不一样，价格也不一样。
[主播] 他可以选不同的。
[嘉宾] 选的是的。
[主播] 你可以选开心果和腰果。或者开心果和松子，或者腰果和松子。就是ABC三个组合一共可以组几种。
[嘉宾] ABAC和BC。
[嘉宾] 包好松子以后价格会贵一点，因为松子本身就比较贵。
[主播] 嗯。很好啊。
[主播] 需要鹏自己拍吧。
[主播] 杂志又可以拍了。
[嘉宾] 对，杂志可以拍了。
[主播] 汉森，汉森在门口呢。
[嘉宾] 来吧。来吧，汉森啊，一块唠吧。
[主播] 汉森家是铁岭的是吧？
[嘉宾] 铁岭的。
[主播] 松子老乡。
[嘉宾] 大。
[主播] 我们俩晚上好。
[嘉宾] 你问他认识你吗？
[主播] 我来北京来的可能比他早一些。因为
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 松子听著亲切。
[嘉宾] 新农哥的东西都很很不错。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 然后这个就是大家喜欢自己拍就可以了。
[嘉宾] 好，来下一个。
[主播] 下一个啥？
[嘉宾] 小曲奇。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 它挺可爱的。
[嘉宾] 确实。
[主播] 小孩应该很喜欢吃。
[主播] 这是黄油，黄油的。
[嘉宾] 里面的配料表很干净。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 没错。想买粉黄油，使用玉米淀粉糖霜，然后各种口味，草莓的就草莓粉。对吧，然后延续焦糖就是焦糖酱，然后浓情可可就是可可粉，然后抹油。
[主播] 对，配料很干净啊。
[嘉宾] 没错。
[主播] 小的时候想吃这种东西还是比较难的，但现在就很多了。
[主播] 所以你说一代孩子他这个快乐的这种满足的点。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 对，他的快乐的这个门槛会越来越高，快乐的预值会越来越高，因为他从小啥都见过。
[嘉宾] 获得太多了。
[主播] 哎，他得到的太多，反而可能快乐没有那么多了，想吃立马就有。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 是不是？
[嘉宾] 对的。
[嘉宾] 他没有那个过程。
[嘉宾] 所以应该怎么办？
[主播] 不给孩子买了。
[嘉宾] 哎，说到我心里去了。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 买了之后家长自己偷偷的吃。
[嘉宾] 放到大衣柜上面。
[主播] 不子应该光明正大的吃，让他知道你得到这个东西需要付出一些。
[嘉宾] 给他关在外面，他扒著玻璃这样看。
[主播] 对，就是从小啥也别给孩子买。他得过的苦一点。
[主播] 他这样偶尔得到一次他就会开心嘛。
[主播] 所以像这么好吃的东西建议家长买了自己偷偷吃。
[嘉宾] 确实。
[主播] 不要让孩子知道。
[嘉宾] 一般直接拍到单位。
[主播] 对，就是快递地址直接改成单位。
[嘉宾] 对的。
[主播] 孩子儿孙自有儿孙福，他长大自己挣钱自己买。
[嘉宾] 这句话我特别同意。
[主播] 是吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 但其实这句话挺受用的。
[主播] 你是不是你小时候让他把福都想了，长大之后每天都可无聊可痛苦的。
[主播] 还有什么能让我开心的？
[嘉宾] 还有啥我没见过的。
[主播] 去鸡饼吃过了，开心子吃这个什么松子。
[嘉宾] 开心果松子吃腻了。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 对吧。
[主播] 都是你把他害了呀，你都是你已经让他见过的这世界所有的精彩。
[嘉宾] 就是。
[主播] 他彻底失去了幸福的能力。
[主播] 杂志给人家了。
[嘉宾] 杂志加杂志加在二号链接啊，需要朋友可以自己拍，五天内发货的。
[主播] 他这应该是每个月给你寄一个。所以你得确定你的地址能收到。
[嘉宾] 嗯嗯嗯，对。
[嘉宾] 我之前看过一个一个视频，就现在的90后包括00后做父母了。00后应该还没做父母，应该是90后啊。我们这年龄往上往下的都应该做父母了。
[主播] 然后呢？
[嘉宾] 没事。
[嘉宾] 然后那个孩子在那想买东西，爸爸妈妈不给买，还在那哭，爸爸妈妈在那看著。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 就是你哭多长时间要陪著你。
[嘉宾] 就主打一个我走过你的路，让你无路可走。
[主播] 不一样的教育方式。
[主播] 酸奶配曲奇。
[嘉宾] 这给安排的吃完。
[主播] 这这碗都是吃胖的。
[嘉宾] 真能笑。
[主播] 这俩能搭配吗？
[嘉宾] 搭配。
[主播] 不是你酸奶都没了。
[嘉宾] 对啊。
[主播] 再倒点呗。再倒点。
[嘉宾] 这其实应该我觉得你拿手给它先揉碎了，放在里面一搅拌。
[主播] 这个吗？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 这边是咸味的。你试试。
[嘉宾] 我就。
[主播] 咱们点岁了。
[嘉宾] 就这样。
[主播] 玩买的是吧？
[嘉宾] 轻轻的，轻轻的。
[主播] 我我哎呀。
[嘉宾] 然后一般。
[主播] 你这行，我这不行，我手汗太重了。
[主播] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 其实还蛮好玩的。
[主播] 谁有错了。
[嘉宾] 必须的。
[嘉宾] 确实饿了。
[主播] 然后我们现在曲奇在一号链接，酸奶在二号链接。
[嘉宾] 曲奇在一号链接，酸奶在二号链接。
[嘉宾] 没错。
[主播] 有朋友说好吃吗？
[主播] 有朋友说刚有个朋友说三个大恶人。
[嘉宾] 三个恶人。
[主播] 饥饿的饿。
[嘉宾] 那我当哪个呢？算了，我不选了。
[主播] 分奶是哪个吧？
[嘉宾] 张宇辉老师说的，可能得到太多，预值就被提高了。
[主播] 但其实像我感觉我得到的也蛮多的，但看到今天那个杂志的时候，如何治保，应该以前可能接触的非常少，没有看过这样。
[主播] 像这种类似于当代文学作家，他们在百家争鸣，给大家创造这些文学价值，你得看到这样的一套。
[主播] 人民文学他主要因为他以前他更多是在作家圈里影响力大。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 他是一个专业性较强的杂志。
[主播] 就像刚蔡老师提到的，他如果能在上面发表他都感觉很开心啊，有一种被肯定的感觉。
[嘉宾] 被认可的感觉。
[主播] 所以呢他的专业性和文学性无庸置疑，但是他以前的可能是作家圈里头。我们今天藉著这样一个好的机会让更多人知道了它。
[嘉宾] 做了一个给自己积德的事情，我觉得是。
[主播] 非常幸福的一件事。
[嘉宾] 积福报的。
[嘉宾] 今天确实我从头到尾。
[主播] 我像是一场访谈。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 像你们在唠家常，是吧？
[嘉宾] 对，很亲。
[主播] 东东是。
[主播] 都是非常委婉的指出了我的。
[嘉宾] 没有没有。
[主播] 没有主题，没有主题。
[嘉宾] 唠家常有啥主题。
[主播] 你回家给你妈，咱今晚这个充满。
[嘉宾] 那是不是说白了，你回去你敢这么说。你说你到别人家里面到隔壁二大爷你把充满。
[主播] 咱定一下今天晚上家庭会议的主题。不要跟唠家常。
[嘉宾] 没有，没有啊。
[主播] 没有。
[嘉宾] 圆满了。
[主播] 我想这磨著比较了。
[嘉宾] 你当著48万人面你给我做这总结。
[主播] 完了。
[嘉宾] 我说的，我听到了，赶紧把那账号先注销了。离开人世间的纷扰我先。
[主播] 连夜离开中国。
[主播] 连夜开始秀年。
[嘉宾] 哎呀，太吓人了。
[主播] 先喝个喝个酸奶压惊。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 我说方碗，这明明是圆的。
[嘉宾] 这是正儿八经的圆形。
[主播] 你看，等会给你个，你看，就为什么我们要选择这种脚的这个碗呢？
[主播] 对吧？
[嘉宾] 有弧度。
[主播] 哎，温润，温润如玉。
[嘉宾] 对的。
[主播] 陌上君子。
[嘉宾] 陌上。
[嘉宾] 陌上玻璃碗。
[主播] 圆圆圆圆。
[嘉宾] 圆圆圈圈圆圆，圆圆圆圆。
[主播] 下一个吧。
[主播] 就给大家过了，准备上大仓了。
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 啥我吃饱了，你该上大仓了。
[嘉宾] 你早点说那是甜品啊。
[主播] 先来聊会。
[主播] 我以为这碗就卖个呢。
[嘉宾] 当主食吃的。
[主播] 我吃饱了，他先告诉我，甜品结束了，开始上大仓了。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 先被著手。
[主播] 给宇辉先整两碗酸奶。
[嘉宾] 是吧？
[主播] 完了吧。
[嘉宾] 好。
[嘉宾] 把那个肯德基麦当劳拿上来。
[主播] 这这瓜子磕饱了，你也不说我以为今晚的饭就是瓜子呢。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 走比你悲惨的，给你这个更小的，吃的是瓜子皮。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 太惨了。
[嘉宾] 永远都在皮里。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 呼应上了。
[主播] 从小就听爸妈说，营养全在皮里。
[嘉宾] 这大圆盒子。
[主播] 哎哟我。
[主播] 那蒙古。
[主播] 这大圆盒子。
[嘉宾] 有发展啊，有前途。
[主播] 哎，这是一个东西还是两个东西？
[嘉宾] 一个东西。
[主播] 对，他只是送你礼遇你一包。
[嘉宾] 就这些是从里头拿出来的。
[主播] 对对对对对。
[主播] 我看看有什么东西啊。
[主播] 牛脊骨三斤，牛腩肉两斤，牛腿肉两斤，牛肋排三斤。
[嘉宾] 来自于内蒙古的。
[主播] 然后这也是黄牛肉。
[嘉宾] 大家其实平时吃牛肉现在可能考虑到一点就是吃那种带点黄标的。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 这种感觉口感可能更好一些。
[主播] 香啊。
[嘉宾] 对，香。
[主播] 吃吧。
[嘉宾] 来吧，你吃点。
[主播] 我天我天天吃饱了。
[嘉宾] 你天天吃饱了。
[主播] 哎。
[嘉宾] 那这就没办法了，我就不能让你了。
[主播] 我光念这个肉啊，三斤两斤两斤三斤的，我这过都念饱了，真的。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 一共到。
[主播] 三斤牛脊骨，两斤牛腩肉，两斤牛腿肉，还有三斤牛肋条。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 牛肋排。
[主播] 十斤。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 这送人，送礼，走亲，访友。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 是不是？
[嘉宾] 对的。
[主播] 有留面。
[主播] 去去女孩东西会去女孩家里定亲，提了一箱牛肉。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 再提了两桶油，一袋米，一袋面。
[主播] 最好头后面都睡的板平。
[嘉宾] 现在聪明。
[主播] 然后这个白色衬衫扎在了裤子里。
[嘉宾] 穿了一个。
[主播] 然后最好再开著辆帕萨特。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 山东丈母娘心目中的女婿。
[嘉宾] 你得看大葱啊。
[主播] 最好再有个事业编。
[嘉宾] 对吧。
[主播] 中午上班的。
[主播] 然后媳妇最好是一个老师。
[嘉宾] 对吧。
[主播] 然后他们俩的孩子以后儿子呢去事业编，女儿呢去当老师。
[嘉宾] 完了。
[嘉宾] 他已经开始做上梦了。
[嘉宾] 但没事，你这个圆梦的时间是比较长的，为什么？因为这个牛肉的保质期是18个月。
[主播] 给的时间比较久。
[嘉宾] 一年半啊。
[主播] 只要在18个月内送出去。
[嘉宾] 不到前两年。
[主播] 来这松子的老乡啊。
[主播] 你看有朋友有朋友说不行，你还差一件行政夹克。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[主播] 我给你安排。
[嘉宾] 不就行政夹克吗？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 他们说你这是复品。
[主播] 你这是你这是你不了解，你不同一点人去事故啊你这。
[主播] 你就不通人性的。
[嘉宾] 当年的特点已经被摸透了。
[主播] 摸透了。
[嘉宾] 挺好玩。
[主播] 先准备。
[主播] 现在不行，现在观众已经把我们拿捏的死死的了。
[主播] 昨天我最近不是一直好多人这个说要要要要买化妆品。
[主播] 我说不卖。
[主播] 然后呢。
[嘉宾] 你是你说的最近有好多人，那好多人指的是哪些人？
[主播] 就是这些消费者们。然后在咱们评论区还有去我评论区。
[主播] 然后呢这个。
[主播] 说不卖。
[主播] 然后就有人说。
[主播] 啊，你都不允许我们买化妆品，那你为什么要卖这个白酒？
[主播] 我说，哎，对啊。
[主播] 白酒不是这个成本也很低吗？
[嘉宾] 哦。
[主播] 然后你偏要卖。
[主播] 我说有道理。
[主播] 我竟然无言以对，我说那干脆白酒也别卖了。
[嘉宾] 逆向思维。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 因为我。
[主播] 反著想。
[主播] 因为我讲不过他，因为他说的有道理。
[主播] 然后又有人留言说，不卖算什么本事，有种你以后别喝了，你戒了呀，我。
[嘉宾] 因为我讲不过他，因为他说的有道理。
[主播] 你护手霜一般。
[嘉宾] 我我心里好奇，我说我怎么就成为我最讨厌的人？
[嘉宾] 你你成为你最讨厌的人，我说我咋了？
[嘉宾] 我擦你脸太皮了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 都没从被窝里出来。
[主播] 我快乐我出门了，我也是到了你们人呢，其实谁都没到。
[嘉宾] 然后第二个呢，它又它又一整箱的量又大。
[嘉宾] 然后你知道，我今天睡觉之后觉得身体轻盈。
[主播] 你不是你俩坐，你俩坐。
[嘉宾] 你心疼啥呢？
[嘉宾] 有礼盒。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 花钱。
[嘉宾] 实惠。
[主播] 那你要批准了。
[主播] 没有必要蒙你啊。
[嘉宾] 你别给人胡说。
[嘉宾] 脱脂奶饱和，是是是来著。
[主播] 选品，pass掉，嗯，确实。
[嘉宾] 身体轻盈，清飘飘，也不疼。
[嘉宾] 有空看出来这东西会是真不会卖货，这一会会已经把已经把这个。
[嘉宾] 牛肉啊，需要朋友自己拍，一共是十斤，三斤牛几骨，两斤牛腩，两斤牛腿肉，三斤牛肋条。
[主播] 然后有原味的，有五香的，然后当然还会有一个，这个是礼遇的一盒是吗？
[嘉宾] 我之前其实还问过石老师，我说你能不能带我去你当年写出那去那地方。
[主播] 然后第二就是它的很多词呢，听著非常的怎么说呢，比较粗放，有张力。
[嘉宾] 就是你你只要对这个脂肪不是医生要求的那种，那你买全脂，因为全脂它好喝。
[嘉宾] 我他有一种感觉被你们俩蒙了，你问他们是不是？
[主播] 对吧，你说以前也没有那么多的这个钢筋铁骨高楼大厦的。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 我们。
[主播] 但是又很生动。
[主播] 对，有个礼盒一个，礼遇的一个礼盒，一共四盒。
[嘉宾] 你不要现在买那好多人过年送的人情。
[嘉宾] 是不是？
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 瓜子吃多了，口渴了，来个牛奶呗。
[主播] 当代年轻人现状，一位冷酷的鸽子路过。
[嘉宾] 然后又有人留言说不卖算什么本事，有种你以后别喝了，你戒了呀我。
[嘉宾] 没事。
[主播] 又地大物博的。
[嘉宾] 他说可以倒是可以。
[嘉宾] 行吧。
[主播] 好。
[嘉宾] 那种感觉啊。
[主播] 嗯，这其实是脂肪香气。
[主播] 46位朋友看呢。
[嘉宾] 他说这么多人意见你都不听，你就不知己见。
[主播] 第一次实现了当家做主。
[嘉宾] 我站著是因为以前当老师习惯了，而且这样显高嘛，主要是。
[主播] 我并没有那么想播这个什么这么黄金的，就是你你你响几点播就几点播。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 不一定。
[嘉宾] 对，你知道在陕西啊，小偷不是贼吗？他是个名词对吧？
[嘉宾] 我记得我这个平常觉得胸闷气短，然后觉得肝脏都在疼那种感觉，今天哇。
[主播] 行。
[嘉宾] 我说错了。
[嘉宾] 46位朋友。
[主播] 就是不好喝。
[主播] 那其他没事，咱们18个月内啊。
[嘉宾] 但是他说雨灰就没有问题，但关键那个地方在内蒙古。
[嘉宾] 这你把盒子拆完之后，你发现我我我我还是前一段时间我才知道，我以为好多奶箱它全都是奶。
[主播] 然后咱们这个的话就属于是逢年过节，家里边可能客桌，就桌子上面，茶机上面常备的一个。
[主播] 咱这加点条件也是挺好的。
[主播] 那么多人啊。
[嘉宾] 就是不好喝。
[主播] 我可能来不了，那鸽子在那盘子里面盖著。
[主播] 但是咱们因为是有一年四季嘛，四季分明，那所以说夏天。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 东西读两遍了。
[嘉宾] 卖货呢，卖货呢，卖货我也说实话，它就是不好喝。
[嘉宾] 来下一个。
[主播] 还有。
[嘉宾] 命运开始由自己掌控。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 没有问题。
[嘉宾] 我感觉又回到了最初的从前。
[主播] 站著。
[主播] 吃完瓜子喝牛奶，你是真不怕孩子上火啊。
[嘉宾] 大家还有什么？
[主播] 饱和。
[主播] 就上500单了。
[嘉宾] 我命由我不由天。
[嘉宾] 因为我以前当老师的时候，就就是站著讲课，所以时间久了，我要坐下的话，你你发现我。
[主播] 贼。
[嘉宾] 饱和。
[嘉宾] 你你不就是自己最讨厌的人吗？
[主播] 没还没卖完。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 就上500单了。
[嘉宾] 但是他可以成为一个副词。
[主播] 一个大家族都来了，46个人。
[主播] 把油脱脂的奶吗？下掉。
[主播] 那天的直播，穿插可以那个录像。
[嘉宾] 口红。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 都是兄弟，我怎么会割你呢，搂著你，都是哥们。
[主播] 行。
[嘉宾] 你别老建上就说话嘛。
[嘉宾] 这个东西好，这个东西贼好吃。
[嘉宾] 来自内蒙的牛，299一共十斤。
[嘉宾] 因为他是这些副主席嘛，他出省他得报备，比较麻烦。
[嘉宾] 口红。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 又回到解放前。
[主播] 可能之前是毛衣穿多了。
[主播] 人咋不说夏天在外面说话凉快呢？
[嘉宾] 他整天在这劝我无意无比无辜，你倒是无我呀，你都无辜呀，你都无比呀，你无意呀，对吧？
[主播] 主餐瓜子。
[嘉宾] 当然有的人他是医生建议的那个，他是不不得不，你健身餐，健身餐你吃健身餐，健身餐好吃吗？就那种感觉。
[主播] 口红应该是不太现实。
[嘉宾] 不行不行不行，这个做不到啊，这个。
[嘉宾] 结果它下面还放一层那个垫的纸，那意思是啥呀？
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 没事我们听得懂。
[嘉宾] 牛肉。
[主播] 叫做一个孩子的痛苦。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 好，没问题。
[嘉宾] 你咋不说。
[主播] 餐后饮料牛奶。
[嘉宾] 这这这种图的意义在哪里？
[嘉宾] 我也不能理解为什么它就有这种表达效果，你刚才咱提到汉字的多种应用应用嘛。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 从容。
[主播] 理解。
[嘉宾] 也不一定。
[主播] 常备的，然后预算呢就是比如说你喜欢吃原味，喜欢吃五香基本都能涵盖到，如果你只喜欢其中的一个口味是你的挚爱的话，那你就挑单独的那四盒就OK了。
[嘉宾] 我说行吧，下一个，然后我看到导演灯。
[嘉宾] 你看。
[嘉宾] 所以呢。
[主播] 一天。
[主播] 毛客儿大销，自己可以拍一拍。
[主播] 今天穿的是衬衣，把这个领子打开了，有道理。
[嘉宾] 然后我还问李老师，我说你写的东牧场下牧场你能带我去吗？
[主播] 显得外头盒子很大。
[主播] 卖把毛客，咱在外面别闹，慢慢聊，对，别吃。
[嘉宾] 算下来还是很优惠的，一斤不到30块钱。
[主播] 你还换成品啥的，你就可以，还便宜，怎么可能，都没有过这个品。
[嘉宾] 这个作者是采访，你发现我坐那坐的沙发深的我我就是。
[主播] 从此称出发。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 你倒是言行合一知行合一呀。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 毛客儿。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 不。
[主播] 这家庭。
[嘉宾] 导演灯。
[嘉宾] 我我现在我现在已经没有办法言行一致了，没有办法知行合一了都。
[主播] 毛客儿。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 那我每天给你聊天的时候，你不是还给我表情包的吗？
[嘉宾] 毛客儿。
[主播] 搭配挺均衡的，啊。
[主播] 饭前吃饭后吃，健身餐。
[主播] 你有没有去饭店吃过那种什么肉，底下给你放一堆白菜，你说那意义是啥？
[主播] 对。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 那东北就是嘎嘎，嘎嘎香。
[嘉宾] 你一晚上没卖货，你能卖一点吗？
[主播] 大瓜子。
[主播] 可以啊。
[嘉宾] 容光焕发。
[嘉宾] 那把毛客是谁？
[主播] 我上哪卖这个品，那只能留下。
[主播] 他们说他们也想来这个跟咱们聚餐。
[嘉宾] 真的是，你以为那是好吃你才吃的吗？
[主播] 你但是夏天来更好一些，冬天太冷了。
[主播] 红烧清炖炖烤都没啥问题啊。
[主播] 就是平常记扣子记太紧，勒著了。
[嘉宾] 这种图的意义在哪里？
[嘉宾] 我第一次听说的时候我不知道，我说什么是嘎嘎好吃，他说就是刚刚的意思。
[主播] 毛客就是瓜子。
[主播] 东北就毛客儿。
[主播] 你真的是。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 我只能来大宝给你讲。
[嘉宾] 理解。
[主播] 这也不知道。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 就是。
[主播] 哎，你吃东北玩过不啊？
[主播] 主要是现在来讲吧，我也不知道最近怎么回事啊，大家这个最近总生病，大家都生病啊。
[嘉宾] 咱找一个不多的呀，现在。
[嘉宾] 我。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 就是。
[主播] 你缺氧。
[嘉宾] 瓜子给大家过了，有需要的朋友你拍吧。
[嘉宾] 哎哟，那那么大场地可能不太好找呀。
[嘉宾] 就是看到那些文字就是你就对那充满憧憬，好奇，充满了向往和期待。
[嘉宾] Can anyone, can anyone tell me? What is the point of these stupid pictures?
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 啥都不知道了。
[嘉宾] 我看了半天，我都不知道怎么反驳他，所以我把他留言给删了。
[主播] 你真的是。
[主播] 明白。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 没事慢慢来。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[嘉宾] 我没理解。
[嘉宾] 这没啥选的。
[主播] 哎，我考考你啊，最近不是耳边特别火，被这个东北特别火。
[主播] 来看看啊，汉森下回就别老问这个啥。
[嘉宾] 我说很很好呀，我都还不理解嘎嘎，你给我来个刚刚。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 生气。
[嘉宾] 瓜子儿啊。
[嘉宾] 就剩不多了。
[嘉宾] 为啥放白菜？
[主播] 去东北玩过不啊，就吃点几次去放飞一下。
[嘉宾] 最近不太好找，这个场地还找老久的。
[主播] 来吧。
[嘉宾] 牛肉啊。
[主播] 挺好，大家已经找到了你的这个怎么说呢？
[嘉宾] 就不吃的话，你别放它，你那白菜可以再做一道菜，醋溜白菜啊。
[主播] 但是会更香一点，像咱们平时吃那个烧烤，你吃那个肥肉，它好正经啊。
[嘉宾] 这是啥？
[主播] 三胖的二。
[主播] 毛客。
[主播] 考考你东北话。
[主播] 买起来吧，朋友们，这个是十斤啊。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 毛客。
[主播] 哎，28号小秘密能告诉他们吗？
[主播] 咱要不去一圈那个额尔古纳河吧。
[嘉宾] 他说刚刚的意思就是的意思。
[主播] 毛客。
[主播] 但有时间吧。
[主播] 妙妙妙。
[嘉宾] 那必须的嘛。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[嘉宾] 你你开始铺垫啥了？
[主播] 闭上眼就感觉身临其境。
[主播] 他们这个瓜子好像有个说法，说这个里面好像几乎是没有什么灰尘。
[嘉宾] 十斤。
[主播] 毛客。
[嘉宾] 软肋了。
[主播] 我先考汉森啊。
[嘉宾] What is the point?
[嘉宾] 啥？
[嘉宾] 瓜子儿。
[主播] 对，有时间的。
[嘉宾] 你看到吃子燕老师，你不会说毛客，可不是。
[主播] 不知道怎么做的，还有炖肉料，直接放里面这个炖就可以了啊。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 没有铺垫。
[嘉宾] 你考我啊。
[主播] 哦。
[主播] 占地儿。
[主播] 管理哲学。
[主播] 然后比吃瘦的会更加的香一点，你再远一点。
[嘉宾] 猛击啊。
[嘉宾] 哇。
[嘉宾] 就毛客。
[主播] 算了，不告诉他们了。
[主播] 你这人呢。
[嘉宾] 睁开眼就开始卖毛客。
[主播] 我我只是想跟大家说啊，我说这个没事啊，这个一是多运动，二是别老这个不好好吃饭。
[主播] 咱们有个人。
[主播] 行吧，你。
[主播] 先找到后猛击。
[主播] 毛客。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 先把你把饼给你画了啊。
[嘉宾] 是吧？
[嘉宾] 你能理解吗？
[主播] 地道吗？
[嘉宾] 你看。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[主播] 额尔古纳河。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 我能理解啊。
[主播] 不告诉他们小秘密。
[主播] 高级管理哲学。
[嘉宾] 我我我看到我无法理解，那你把盒子做小点，别浪费材料不就行了吗？
[嘉宾] 然后呢，今天下午在办公室开会，我就投票，民主决策。
[嘉宾] 他为啥要我。
[嘉宾] 是吧？
[主播] 我先我先考当地的。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 哎，这点都干不下去。
[主播] 下次一定。
[主播] 他可以在就是咱们甚至在一个直播间里面，当著40多位观众，然后咱们在直播带货的时候还可以再讨论他，这就是他存在的意义。
[主播] 你光是炖啊，你是烤，比如说有这个牛肋排，你是煮，然后你是包一个火锅，牛蝎子，里面都有啊，涵盖的比较全面。
[嘉宾] 好。
[嘉宾] 行行。
[嘉宾] 下次一定。
[主播] 又学了这个。
[嘉宾] 你用A来解释B,B来解释C是吧，你这套娃，他说刚刚就是嘎嘎，嘎嘎就是，就是广广。
[嘉宾] 可以。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[主播] 哎。
[主播] 你要如果说哥们，我真的对你很失望，用东北话怎么说？
[嘉宾] 就是无法解决问题，就解决到制造问题的提出问题的人。
[嘉宾] 还还有啥，还有啥词？
[主播] 我开玩笑。
[主播] 就以雨灰为代表的。
[嘉宾] 28号我请他们吃饭的。
[主播] 你哥们搂著另一个鸽子说，下次一定。
[嘉宾] 毛客。
[主播] 嗯，就先卖过。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 啥时候放假呀？
[主播] 他很认真答应我，可以。
[嘉宾] 哎哟。
[主播] 不行。
[主播] 还有啥词，你得看品呢。
[嘉宾] 说是很很严谨，几乎没有。
[主播] 保质期12个月啊，朋友们，然后来自于新西兰。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 你得大。
[嘉宾] 你看我现在腰带这一斤是最小，最后这个。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 你一想都在我故乡。
[嘉宾] 我很害怕。
[主播] 哎，据说28号要放假了。
[主播] 是吧？大吃小小被吃，你看过那个那个长江七号里面。
[主播] 放你鸽子。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我跟你总结。
[嘉宾] 就不敢说太绝对。
[嘉宾] 我又一次输了。
[嘉宾] 谁？
[嘉宾] 我跟你总结。
[主播] 这其实跟大家就是分享一个就是说开奶剂。
[主播] 哎。
[主播] 咱们。
[主播] 还有一个啥？挠挠。
[主播] 又想吃饭。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[主播] 都快买儿童腰带了。
[主播] 据称，据称啊。
[嘉宾] 哎哟。
[主播] 你如果遇到一个东北朋友，你比如说你俩送礼，你拿东西，他要是这个发音在一声和二声。
[嘉宾] 他们再次拒绝了我。
[主播] 可以的。
[嘉宾] 挠挠。
[嘉宾] 对呀。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 我怕油油的不快。
[嘉宾] 你就说出来了。
[嘉宾] 还是松。
[主播] 挠挠。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 合理性。
[嘉宾] 覆盖也比较多嘛。
[嘉宾] 这个问题，这也没有办法回应问题。
[嘉宾] 我常常发现我跟东东无法融入。
[嘉宾] 你就在英语中，就是你想要你的话严谨，就怎么样吗？就用被动语态。
[主播] 还是松垮。
[主播] 休一天。
[嘉宾] 还有挠挠吗？
[嘉宾] 好好好。
[主播] 你别理他，他给我发一堆几八的表情包。
[嘉宾] 他们说凭什么不能卖？
[嘉宾] 什么？
[主播] 他怎么说，他现在。
[嘉宾] 说到尔古纳河，他第一次成为那啥边界历史考一个从什么时候开始？
[主播] 挠挠。
[主播] 多下点。
[嘉宾] 没事。
[主播] 行了。
[主播] 开奶剂，啥意思呢？
[嘉宾] 挠挠。
[嘉宾] 行吧。
[嘉宾] 28号我们停播一天。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 哎哟。
[主播] 挠挠。
[主播] 就是这个。
[嘉宾] 而且我还穿著加厚的。
[主播] 我在这站著就跟著，我就跟那猴孩子似的，行了吧。
[嘉宾] 所以呢？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 你下干啥？
[主播] 让你破费了。
[嘉宾] 所以要么删除问题，要么解决提出问题的人。
[嘉宾] 我说你们这些错词就好像是在漫山遍野黑土地那个农场周围动物发出的叫声，然后收集在一起整理就成了语言中的一个点睛之笔。
[主播] 所以呢？
[主播] 天天休假。
[嘉宾] 就他好多梗，我就想卖天是干啥？
[主播] 那牛妈妈的刚生完宝宝之后，然后它产的那个奶就开奶剂的奶。
[主播] 所以是有什么好消息吗？
[主播] 他太瘦了。
[主播] 不。
[嘉宾] 想上班。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 不好意思。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 咋呢？
[嘉宾] 要了。
[主播] 没事没事。
[主播] 我还发哥，他还发几八。
[主播] 我没有想上班的意思啊，我就是只是感慨一下。
[主播] 没有那种就现场什么抽那个什么手机啊，搞点气啊这种活动啊，对吗？有吗？
[主播] 他太瘦了。
[主播] 哎。
[主播] 三声和四声人就不想要。
[嘉宾] 哎哎。
[嘉宾] 我现在还在跟他们。
[嘉宾] 我从上个月那那几天到现在已经瘦了十十几斤了。
[主播] 挺好。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 哎哟。
[嘉宾] 这个是24瓶的。
[嘉宾] 你看看看评论区，能不能把那些全部设为禁词。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[嘉宾] 好喝是吧？
[嘉宾] 删除他。
[主播] 然后我们今天这个牛奶是84,到手24盒。
[主播] 你放弃了。
[主播] 是来听你。
[嘉宾] 谢谢。
[嘉宾] 就是。
[嘉宾] 据说。
[嘉宾] 我们签订了一个什么从此尔古纳河就为了边界。
[主播] 这个不能拿，这是给孩子别撕吧，哎。
[主播] 正常来讲一年360天，它能有300天左右是在产奶的。
[嘉宾] 还在抗争。
[主播] 对，咱也不能太太那个。
[主播] 你比如说你看这个东西，你说汉森给我拿东西，啊。
[主播] 你还在抗争。
[嘉宾] 或者拉黑他。
[主播] 据说。
[主播] 我喝口奶。
[主播] 我给你找找，互联网老人我这属于。
[嘉宾] 我还在抗争。
[嘉宾] 有点虚假。
[嘉宾] 谁说的不知道。
[嘉宾] 我就是完全无法融入你们俩的交流。
[主播] 你就享受。
[嘉宾] 我我看不到了。
[主播] 都没人看了，现在不敢看评论区啊，然后看一眼，哦，哦。
[嘉宾] 那天结果你们都休息，我上班，那怕你失望，你要真是想上班是这。
[主播] 不平等条约。
[嘉宾] 你就享受一下。
[主播] 据说的。
[嘉宾] 抽中的人开心，没抽中的人咋办？所以所以我把这个钱肯定是花了。
[嘉宾] 你说你说你送我东西。
[主播] 我想这个没有这个必要了吧。
[主播] 4.0克优质主蛋白啊。
[主播] 享受啥？
[嘉宾] 哎哎。
[主播] 小儿生气。
[主播] 这样才能获得后代。
[嘉宾] 就是说话的人就不清楚。
[嘉宾] 啥？
[主播] 我很赞同。
[主播] 来，拿两毛客。
[主播] 享受一下这个嗯，你可以用视频的名义。
[主播] 哎。
[嘉宾] 又减肥，这不是减肥。
[嘉宾] 24啊，朋友们。
[主播] 那可能有些朋友们就是中爱它开奶剂的奶，可能觉得更加的欣赏一些那样的味道。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 你不出条约，非常好。
[主播] 我现在就是不想提出问题。
[嘉宾] 就是刚刚好吃，好吃，嘎嘎好吃。
[主播] 这不是减肥。
[主播] 我不行。
[主播] 哎哎。
[嘉宾] 其实我每天都活在互联网上，但是他说好多东西我反应半天。
[主播] 然后这个盖含量是122毫克，属于是符合国标GB2860的高盖牛奶。
[嘉宾] 我不行。
[主播] 基本上就不超三个字。
[嘉宾] 这是吃不下睡不著的。
[主播] So this is pure milk。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 跟谁签的？
[主播] 咱直播间给东东改造一下。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 就是普通的表达形式。
[嘉宾] 跟沙皇。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 往上走的，这就想要。
[主播] 100% whole milk。
[主播] 就是能忽略，就是有一些它反复出现的情况下。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 据说怎么样。
[嘉宾] 然后昨晚回去，昨晚回去把自己关醉，睡著了。
[主播] 沙皇。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 但是你放心，我会以每个人都有的方式给你们发过年红包。
[主播] 我播啥？
[主播] 这就是这就是东北话的一个神奇之处。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[嘉宾] 净土。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 如果是。
[主播] 奖你一盒瓜子。
[主播] 简单来讲，蛋白质含量也比较高，如果需要品质比较好的牛奶，而且肩盘的话性价比也很好。
[主播] OK。
[主播] 没事，也是知行合一。
[主播] 鸽子表情包，我带你冲冲浪接著晚上啊。
[主播] 去感受一下他们呼呼的流程。
[嘉宾] 给他放个手机，放著自己，对吧，练著自己也能谈。
[嘉宾] 就很严谨了。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 那是爱。
[嘉宾] 挺好挺好挺好。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[嘉宾] 太棒了。
[嘉宾] 六声啊。
[嘉宾] 然后我。
[嘉宾] 行。
[主播] 放那吗？
[主播] 这么多。
[主播] 你不是那是爱。
[主播] 反正我觉得确实因为什么呢？
[主播] 就是醉了。
[主播] 三声四声。
[嘉宾] 一罐是250毫升，一共24箱。
[主播] 破心中贼难也是蛮有名的说的，没啥问题。
[主播] 有朋友一直说让我跟汉森坐下，但我们家长辈不是也不是长辈。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 拿回来吧。
[嘉宾] 冲浪啊。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 这就看不上。
[嘉宾] 我看这没有这个必要了吧。
[嘉宾] 今天有一有一条留言触动，真的。
[主播] 咱们这个瓜子是据说79块钱，四罐。
[主播] 就第一个他通过语气词就能说出非常丰富的情感。
[主播] 自己关醉。
[主播] 看了吗？
[嘉宾] 不要用专业设备，用个手机就行。
[主播] 不添加防腐剂啊，不添加色素，老人小孩都好喝，都能喝啊。
[主播] 你看刚才我们总结了这个语言，我觉得很到位的点，就东北人说话很快。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 怎么没教我一下？
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 他让我给你。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 这个月钱我差不多。
[嘉宾] 可靠。
[主播] 我觉得可以有这个必要。
[主播] 但我有权力没收。
[主播] 这么快乐的事情就应该分享一下。
[嘉宾] 你看这个也跟前两天那个一样，就是解决第一个它蛋白质含量和盖含量高。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 人啥都没说。
[嘉宾] 实现独播。
[嘉宾] 破心中贼难啊。
[主播] 就哥哥要说话，或者比我大的人说话的时候，我不敢坐下，我就待著不起来。
[嘉宾] 你看。
[主播] 据说。
[主播] 就这放他鸽子，洗个澡就出门。
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 但是又怎么著？
[主播] 老人小孩都好喝。
[主播] 就那种感觉啊。
[嘉宾] 戳痛，戳到我的痛点了。
[嘉宾] 谁说的？
[主播] 为啥得快？
[嘉宾] 那一天。
[主播] 突然有点心疼。
[主播] 你天天你说你天天擦护手霜不行。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 巨经会神。
[主播] 据说79块钱可以带到四罐。
[嘉宾] 分享一下。
[嘉宾] 黄金档。
[嘉宾] 你那。
[主播] 因为外面太冷了。
[主播] 因为你发的这个声音是三声到四声。
[嘉宾] 建议买全脂的，如果你不介意的话。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 怀疑。
[主播] 他就说了。
[主播] 哎哟。
[主播] 语言文化。
[嘉宾] 把自己排满。
[主播] 其实没有出门。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[嘉宾] 他对我说你没有变成你曾经讨厌的自己吗？
[嘉宾] 我也是。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 哎哟。
[主播] 那东北人多厉害。
[嘉宾] 主要是护手霜都没了。
[主播] 卖卖卖卖。
[嘉宾] 青春把自己排满。
[主播] 突然会心疼。
[嘉宾] 你还是坐著吧。
[主播] 站时间长动上你。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[主播] 我这种。
[主播] 四面出歌。
[主播] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 是吧？
[主播] 对。
[主播] 终于卖完了。
[主播] 没事。
[嘉宾] 中午把自己排满。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 的时候，就是就是站着讲课。
[主播] 所以时间久了，我要坐下的话，你你发现我这个坐着时候，不是采访，你发现我坐那坐的沙发深的我我就是就容易困。
[主播] 对，反应就容易慢。
[嘉宾] 对，你坐就容易反应慢。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 是这样。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 小鹏自己拍吧。
[主播] 就是牛奶啊，一箱有24罐，然后呢，这个蛋白质比较高，4.0克的蛋白质。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 然后盖是122毫克，所以它就是
[嘉宾] 没错。
[主播] 这个营养更丰富些，对于一些朋友，比如说他他自己喝不了那么多，但是他又希望营养多一些，你就你就买这个就行了。
[嘉宾] 对的。
[主播] 这个算下一罐多少钱？
[嘉宾] 嗯哼。
[主播] 三块多钱，不到四块。
[嘉宾] 三。
[嘉宾] 但是4.0的已经很。
[主播] 对，在在这个蛋白质含量里面它的价钱还算很公道了啊。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 有朋友说，啊，所以别人坐下跟你一样高是吧？
[嘉宾] 参考。
[嘉宾] 太棒了。
[主播] 把他给我翻出来。
[嘉宾] 太痛了。
[嘉宾] 好好奖励。
[主播] 太痛了。
[主播] 我给，我给，我给，我给拖一个。
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 别上进，别上进。
[嘉宾] 啊，好好。
[主播] 化悲愤为力量。
[嘉宾] 真正的勇士。
[主播] 你你的鲜血。
[嘉宾] 收回来，收回来。
[主播] 把虾全部都收回来。
[嘉宾] 看着呢。
[主播] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 注意点，注意点。
[主播] 真正的勇士啊。
[嘉宾] 此腰果啊。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 配料就是腰果和盐。
[嘉宾] 79块8,两罐。
[嘉宾] 然后保质期240天。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 哎，刚才说哪个腰果啊？
[主播] 刚才那是三个在一块。
[嘉宾] 三个。
[嘉宾] 哦，这你要单吃腰果，你可以吃这个。
[主播] 这个就是两罐腰果啊。
[嘉宾] 没错。
[主播] 这个才是真正的正八的营养在皮上呢。
[嘉宾] 花青素啊。
[主播] 花青素。
[嘉宾] 然后他还是个那个低。
[主播] 你你嚼一下这皮有多硬。
[嘉宾] 它真的挺好吃的。
[嘉宾] 我平时吃都是带皮吃。
[主播] 我也带皮吃。
[嘉宾] 我有时候带核吃。
[主播] 看一下。
[嘉宾] 你都要把这个剥了吗？
[主播] 那不剥。
[嘉宾] 真的假的。
[主播] 好吃啊。
[嘉宾] 你甚至。
[主播] 有那个焦糊味。
[嘉宾] 咱们。
[主播] 这皮。
[主播] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 都没给你在旁边摆个盘。
[主播] 不好吃吗？
[嘉宾] 这皮有点苦啊。
[主播] 嗯？
[嘉宾] 苦吗？
[主播] 不苦啊。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 买。
[主播] 不苦啊。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 买。
[嘉宾] 那生活苦。
[主播] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 咋突然就emo了。
[主播] 这还是长大了。
[嘉宾] 那实际讲的。
[主播] 现在现在开始。
[嘉宾] 到时间就。
[主播] 白emo了。
[嘉宾] 两天没打睡觉了呀。
[主播] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 这不现在变了。
[主播] 长大了。
[嘉宾] 失眠会让人变笨了。
[嘉宾] 两天没睡觉了，对于你现在美食美刻都是深夜。
[主播] 讲好。
[嘉宾] 不能吃多了，保脆一点，吃多了容易困。
[嘉宾] 只能吃坚果。
[主播] 小鹏自己拍吧。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 我觉得，我觉得还行。
[主播] 我觉得还行。
[主播] 你看，你看大家说皮就是苦的，还还非得是埋汰我。
[主播] 这说明我只。
[主播] 在直播间三个人里头只有我的味觉是正常的。
[主播] 我就是说皮是苦的吧，你们俩非说是甜的。
[嘉宾] 你们俩包皮。
[主播] 没说是甜的，也没说他是苦啊。
[嘉宾] 我接受不了带皮吃。
[嘉宾] 我也是去皮吃。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我也去皮吃。
[嘉宾] 去皮。
[嘉宾] 他吃这么小的虾子把头去了。
[主播] 真可怕。
[嘉宾] 建议你们以后核桃连皮吃。
[嘉宾] 营养都在皮里。
[主播] 我们是能吃苦，我们不是250。
[嘉宾] 好啊，啊。
[主播] 牙受不了。
[嘉宾] 门受不了主要是。
[主播] 把我活干了。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 松子建议连皮吃。
[主播] 虾味一罐。
[主播] 建议连皮吃。
[主播] 营养都在皮里。
[嘉宾] 开心果连皮吃，然后就不开心了。
[主播] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 妈妈开心了。
[主播] 真的是。
[主播] 下位一果。
[主播] 建议连皮吃。
[主播] 营养都在皮里。
[主播] 吃西瓜连皮吃。
[主播] 然后就不开心了。
[主播] 哎呀，妈妈开心了。
[主播] 真的是。
[主播] 那只能拿水送服了。
[主播] 温开水送服吧。
[主播] 对对对。
[主播] 这都咽不下去。
[主播] 嗯，哎，真的。
[主播] 你刚才那个动作，我爸吃药就这样。
[主播] 就我就是喝大胶囊就是水一冲直接这样。
[主播] 我也是，就一吃药，你别管咽不咽下去。
[主播] 就老撞那个墙上。
[主播] 好像扎送那一下就这样。
[主播] 要就以惯性冲下去。
[主播] 这是个仪式感。
[主播] 对童年儿时可能吃到那么一口苦的追忆。
[主播] 哎呀，这药说你准备好了，开始了。
[主播] 甩下去了。
[主播] 就会跟我妈脑袋磕了。
[主播] 咚一下。
[主播] 跟我妈磕大包。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 腰果啊，薛鹏自己拍。
[主播] 他们说螃蟹哥。
[主播] 来啊，我骑那门口。
[主播] 说吃榴莲皮，营养都在皮里。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 那个有点牵强。
[主播] 这主要有点扎嘴。
[主播] 众所周知，榴莲是一个非常好的什么？
[主播] 啊？
[主播] 水果。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 对不起啊。
[主播] 谢谢。
[主播] 我就是下播跟你道歉。
[主播] 是我跟这个世界已经脱轨了吗？
[主播] 为什么我感到格格不入呢？哥哥。哎哟。二哥。最近肯定是阿姨来了，你疯狂看甄嬛传，是吧？嗯。想当格格的心已经溢出了屏幕。我先来吧。我当大哥哥。你非要把直播间弄得没人说话了吗？错了。你非要弄得大家都沉默了吗？汉森基本都害羞的。我先喝一口。刚才我们在这个整个访谈过程中，大家听到琴声，就是汉森一直在。Thank you。太辛苦了。而且几乎是提到哪个，他就开始谈哪个。杨老师提到了Great Gatsby。嗯。Young and beautiful。这个电影还好。还提到了啥？人世间。还提到了人世间。不用提。白蛇。白蛇传。哦。哦。青芝山下白素贞。啊？有青芝山下白素贞。对吧？滴滴滴滴。滴滴滴滴。滴滴滴滴滴滴滴，对吧，唱完这首歌来了三两滴滴。哎呀。你说都得亮吧。我求你。我求你。回家睡睡觉。睡睡觉。我无法理解。我无法理解。我就是个瓜。我就是个瓜。聊那个包。说两话。真烦人啊。自己拍一下。说两话。气了已经，真烦人啊。别不讲啊。而且你看我，于老师说他这个在办公室没有意识到。这风感冒的。嗯。我们之前在15楼。我不是那个在做那个地方在办公室那边角落里。风口。
[主播] 我都没有，我一直以为这楼里是没有空调呢。
[主播] 我每天都穿的棉袄你知道吗？
[主播] 而且整天感冒。
[主播] 我当时我说我今年为啥今年冬天这个身体状态这么差？
[主播] 然后搬上来之后好。
[主播] 你那个你那个。
[主播] 我才一直到原来是因为办公室太冷了。
[主播] 每天都感冒你知道吗？
[主播] 你那是我那个。
[主播] 楼下我整天感冒。
[主播] 整天感冒。
[主播] 我说我咋了？
[主播] 我我我一直都担心你说我我这。
[主播] 我的体质咋回事啊？
[主播] 真的是我。
[主播] 我这该吃吃该喝喝，我都成这样了，我。
[主播] 你那不是一个。
[主播] 今天感冒，我说我操，我我我一动都担心，我说我我这
[主播] 汉森没啥，大家一起唱吧。
[嘉宾] 汉森给大家带来一首白素贞。
[主播] 这是淡水，海水加淡水，海水鱼啊。
[嘉宾] 他能唱啥呀？
[主播] 哎呀，我再看呀，太大了。
[嘉宾] 直接对了。
[嘉宾] 有啥想唱的吗？
[主播] 直接对了。
[嘉宾] 我的体质咋回事啊？
[主播] 鲈鱼啊，海鲈鱼。
[嘉宾] 直接对了。
[嘉宾] 我的体质咋回事啊？
[主播] 鲈鱼啊，海鲈鱼。
[嘉宾] 直接对了。
[嘉宾] 哎呀，哎呀。
[主播] 太吓人了，这是秃兄比线啊。
[主播] 真的是我，我该吃吃该喝喝嘛，我都成这样了，我
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 有啥想唱的吗？
[嘉宾] 那不至于啊。
[嘉宾] 那不至于。
[主播] 有啥，我我没我我没有。
[嘉宾] 你那不是
[嘉宾] 那不可能。
[嘉宾] 我没有。
[主播] 你这干啥，你这刀子都拿出来了。
[主播] 我该交代交代吧，我那段时间，我崩溃了，我说不对不对不对，我这是真的是难道人一过30立马身体机能下降这么快吗？
[主播] 我没啥想唱的。
[嘉宾] 好。
[嘉宾] 切脸了啊。
[嘉宾] 你俩研究研究，把海鲈鱼讲一讲。
[主播] 大家大家让让你唱遇见的。
[主播] 去年冬天还不是这个样子呢，我那两天都有点怀疑自己了。
[主播] 四号一下。
[嘉宾] 来。
[嘉宾] 那我唱遇见。
[主播] 结果搬上了抽风这样，哎好了。
[主播] 咱陕西话不标准。
[嘉宾] 海鲈鱼是个好东西啊。
[主播] 你你就唱普通话的。
[嘉宾] 你那个屋里面跟那拿房，三拿房是。就是就是就是因为楼下动了。
[主播] 当我拿出这份宝典的时候
[嘉宾] 嗯哼。
[嘉宾] 陕西版遇见。
[嘉宾] 来呀。
[主播] 但这
[主播] 咱一起。
[主播] 为啥大家这两天都在说这个呢？
[嘉宾] 遇见。
[主播] 我即使都感冒那么，我都没有怀疑过是因为房间温度
[主播] 谁？
[嘉宾] 嗯，可能火吧。
[主播] 是吧？
[嘉宾] 有怎样的意外。
[嘉宾] 对啊。
[主播] 太低造成的。
[主播] 我遇见谁会有怎样的对白
[嘉宾] 自我怀疑。
[主播] 成大事者不拘小节。
[嘉宾] 你们俩这点啊。
[主播] 我不知道大家对上句话，不是把这歌唱这样，大家对这个这么著迷。
[主播] 你俩这点没拿我当回事。
[主播] 就像我我有时候晚上睡不著，肚子都发疼，肚子咕咕响，我都没有，我都没有怀疑过，哎我睡不著是不是因为没吃饭饿的睡不著。
[嘉宾] 我每一次对陕西话。
[嘉宾] 来。
[主播] 我在多远的以外。
[主播] 想呀。
[嘉宾] 这什么有瘾，是看武林外传时候那通胀。
[嘉宾] 但是这个你这点。
[主播] 这点。
[嘉宾] 就像我晚上的时候
[主播] 我听见风来自地铁。
[嘉宾] 听见冬天离开。
[主播] 就我从来都没有怀疑过自己。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[主播] 同乡遇。
[嘉宾] 从哪来啊？
[嘉宾] 对，就像我晚上的时候，这个阿斯马丁给我推送消息，我解账的时候发现不能支付成功。
[嘉宾] 我你神呢，神呢一节老天爷。
[主播] 神啊。
[嘉宾] 你这老天爷。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 鲈鱼。
[嘉宾] 我给他的建议，是因为他不想让我买。
[主播] 淡水鱼。
[主播] 听见冬天离开。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 嗯哼。
[嘉宾] 我从来不会挣钱，我这预额的问题。
[嘉宾] 大家可以看一下这个表。
[主播] 从来没有怀疑，都没有怀疑过是自己的问题。
[主播] 我在某年某月。
[主播] 常见鱼类的区别和做法。
[嘉宾] 就是这样。
[主播] 某年。
[主播] 他酸奶卖完了加一下。
[主播] 常见的鱼，除了这个，大家看了没？
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 汉森，汉森开始唱歌了。
[嘉宾] 汉森开始唱歌了。
[嘉宾] 听见 动天 的离开。
[嘉宾] 我在某年某月醒过来。
[嘉宾] 我想我等我期待。
[嘉宾] 未来却不能因此安排。
[嘉宾] 阴天 傍晚 的窗外。
[嘉宾] 未来有一个人在等待，在等待。
[嘉宾] 向左向右向前看。
[嘉宾] 爱要拐几个弯才来。
[嘉宾] 我遇见谁会有怎样的对白。
[嘉宾] 我等的人他在多远的未来。
[嘉宾] 我听见风来自地天和人海。
[嘉宾] 我排着队拿着爱的号码牌。
[嘉宾] 我看见我往前飞飞过一片时间海。
[嘉宾] 我们也曾在爱情里受伤害。
[嘉宾] 我看着路梦的入口有点窄。
[嘉宾] 我遇见你是最美丽的意外。
[嘉宾] 终有一天我的谜底会解开。
[主播] 行啊。
[主播] 现在整个各语种已经全部拿捏，是吧？
[嘉宾] 是。
[主播] 避雨的。
[嘉宾] 哎哟。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 喜欢这个。
[主播] 我说再来一遍陕西话，你你是对陕西话有啥执念呢？
[嘉宾] 大家说好好听啊。
[嘉宾] 好好听啊。
[主播] 要不，要不你再唱一段？
[主播] 他们真的是很享受。
[嘉宾] 陕西话我试试啊，但是陕西话唱的必定好听。
[主播] 嗯哼。
[嘉宾] 从阴天从这。
[主播] 从这。
[嘉宾] 阴天。
[嘉宾] 傍晚车窗外。
[主播] 在在哪。
[主播] 好听好听好听。
[嘉宾] 未来有一个人在等待。
[嘉宾] 向左向右向前看。
[嘉宾] 爱要拐几个弯儿才来。
[嘉宾] 我遇见谁会有怎样的对白。
[嘉宾] 我等的人他在多远的未来。
[嘉宾] 我听见风来自地天和人海。
[嘉宾] 我排着队拿着爱的号码牌。
[嘉宾] 我往前飞飞过一片时间海。
[嘉宾] 我们也曾在爱情里受伤害。
[嘉宾] 我看着路梦的入口有点窄。
[嘉宾] 我遇见你是最美丽的意外。
[嘉宾] 终有一天我的谜底会解开。
[主播] 好像调不一样了是吧？
[主播] 好听。
[主播] 太好听啊。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 就很那种。
[主播] 灵活那种感觉。
[主播] 大家说好听的出人意料。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 意料之外。
[主播] 大家期待的。
[未知] 这很好听是吧，
[未知] 就很那种灵活的那种感觉。
[未知] 大家说好听的出人意料，
[未知] 哎呀，
[未知] 意料之外，
[未知] 大家期待的是什么？
[未知] 无法法理解大家陕陕西竟人会有这么大的这个热情。
[未知] 嗯，
[未知] 确实好听啊，
[未知] 确实我觉得确实你要是吧？
[未知] 你嗯陕陕陕西话一般情况下音音调都比较简单。
[未知] 你听啊陕西话比较简单啊，
[未知] 大量的琴声四声嗯，
[未知] 维维度好嘞，
[未知] 唉，
[未知] 嗯这是这个感。
[未知] 第第二，
[未知] 我开始学了吗？
[未知] 你听陕西话，
[未知] 陕西话陕西话，
[未知] 你看陕西花陕，
[未知] 要么是唉唉非常标准，
[未知] 要么是四声，
[未知] 要么是轻声好，
[未知] 陕西话好，
[未知] 非常好，
[未知] 给大家分享一个陆语来啥？
[未知] 陆羽陆羽陆羽，
[未知] 陆陆羽鲈鱼鲈鱼啊，
[未知] 我以为是了解茶神来了。
[未知] 嗯，
[未知] 陕西话怎么说？
[未知] 陆羽正鲈鱼、
[未知] 鲈鱼嗯，
[未知] 哎呀，
[未知] 哎鲈鱼好吃，
[未知] 捧常还味，
[未知] 还好听逆行旅人的陕西话吧。
[未知] 哎呦，
[未知] 那叫逆旅行人，
[未知] 啥叫逆龄？
[未知] 逆行旅人，
[未知] 你再这样，
[未知] 我发脾气来了，
[未知] 逆行可违法的那交通法你是一点安全意识都没有啊。
[未知] 逆行旅人道道，
[未知] 千万条，
[未知] 安全第一，
[未知] 一条警警告一次，
[未知] 对对警告一次啊。
[未知] 逆旅行人太好听了，
[未知] 真的是那我唱的陕西话版的苏轼都来给我托梦了。
[未知] 我跟你说嗯，
[未知] 哎看看什么陕西话，
[未知] 最近没看苏轼更新啊，
[未知] 李白也没更新是吧？
[未知] 他们的动态的好久没更新，
[未知] 行，
[未知] 抖音都没发，
[未知] 他们俩要更新，
[未知] 你也吓一跳了。
[未知] 完了，
[未知] 你这是真的，
[未知] 时隔一千多年再次更新了。
[未知] 李白自己的朋友圈。
[未知] 哎，
[未知] 你敢点赞吗？
[未知] 你这鲈鱼九十九，
[未知] 今天到手四条四条啊。
[未知] 好，
[未知] 嗯，
[未知] 九十九块钱四条。
[未知] 对你那你们俩继续卖货吧，
[未知] 你歇会儿吧，
[未知] 我就加班了，
[未知] 两小时了，
[未知] 我就退下了，
[未知] 回去睡会儿觉吧，
[未知] 向左向右向辛苦了，
[未知] 辛苦了。
[未知] 哎呀，
[未知] 辛苦了，
[未知] 拜拜了，
[未知] 明天我播吗？
[未知] 啊，
[未知] 明天我明天不播呀，
[未知] 年手机辛苦了，
[未知] 明天靠你们了。
[未知] 好嘞嗯，
[未知] 对，
[未知] 给他提提醒一下，
[未知] 哎，
[未知] 不是这往下它会会掉去，
[未知] 我来吧，
[未知] 懂 OK 努力，
[未知] 哪怕给你喝了，
[未知] 默默的几号二十八回吧，
[未知] 二十八号回来是吧？
[未知] 嗯，
[未知] 不是我我后天正常就播了，
[未知] 那后天正常播，
[未知] 但咱是二十八号全体休息啊，
[未知] 大家别走空了啊。
[未知] OK 是的，
[未知] 然后再给大家补充，
[未知] 就是春节档期的电影危机。
[未知] 嗯，
[未知] 不哎不对啊，
[未知] 变物种，
[未知] 你你说会会预计会怎么样？
[未知] 已有三个地方要来是吗？
[未知] 哦，
[未知] 啊，
[未知] 我就放心了。
[未知] 哎，
[未知] 那较好，
[未知] 这个鲈鱼是昨天咱们卖没货了，
[未知] 完天给大家有补的那个鲈。
[未知] 对，
[未知] 有朋友说这个鲈鱼，
[未知] 你们那边五百到六百克的，
[未知] 一条，
[未知] 得卖一百多小两百块钱，
[未知] 那肯定啊，
[未知] 你那是活的开玩笑啊。
[未知] 嗯，
[未知] 我们这个是嗯嗯嗯啊啊，
[未知] 你这突然啊，
[未知] 哎哎呀哎你哎棒啊啊。
[未知] 对对对，
[未知] 咱不是这个一晚上吧，
[未知] 别打别打，
[未知] 别打了，
[未知] 好好好哎。